how many of you have done that in a
prior job i i know i can't say that i
have that's what makes
the relationships that work even better
that's what makes you happy to come into
work and walk through the door what
makes our culture different at filtrust
is is our people is the culture that
we've established what's really great
about it is it's happened so organically
it's happened by grassroots efforts it's
hiring great people because at the end
of the day we want to succeed we want to
win together and
provide a great customer service in
doing so i think as an employee from the
time that you walk in the door you you
feel the energy in the room you feel
everybody coming together for this
common cause which is to provide this
amazing customer service but it's more
than that it's a family environment it's
people who enjoy working together just
in the short amount of time that i've
been here i've gotten to see that
dynamic and how that plays out the
impact filtrates has on my personal life
is the ability to be flexible i come
from a consulting background for the
past 10 years now and before that strong
corporate you know big structural
environments and you know one of the
things that i really wanted to do is
settle down focus have a family get
married and consulting doesn't allow for
that
whereas
my job here at filtrus does it's a job a
job that supplies work-life balance but
also you know a really great environment
for me to continue doing what i love
doing
and a really cool startup environment
where i could actually build something
the way that i empower my employees to
have a voice is by giving them the space
to talk and then doing something that um
not a lot of leaders always do which is
actually take the time to listen
employees will tell you what it is they
need to feel safe what it is they need
to feel successful what it is they need
to feel productive and valued at work
and as leaders it's our job to listen to
that it's our job to take that and make
decisions it's so important that you
don't lose sight of the employee part
it's so important that you're you're
constantly working on building your
culture the downfall that too many
leaders make is they they try to silence
their employees they try to
create policies and create procedures
and create all this structure without
realizing that at the end of the day
we're all
human beings right every single one of
us is unique and different and there's
things that make up who we are and in
order for us to really give employees a
powerful voice we have to recognize that
and we have to not only recognize it but
we have to support it we have to
encourage it and we have to we have to
promote it the one piece of advice that
i give all new employees coming in is
don't be afraid to ask questions
one thing that i found is that everybody
here at this company
is incredibly helpful incredibly driven
to
help others succeed and
don't be shy because nobody here on this
team is shy oftentimes when you start a
new job the first thing you want to do
is you want to come in you want to prove
yourself right you want to
not make mistakes you want to
immediately be successful and we know
that that's not necessarily a reality
and i think what makes filtrus unique is
that we all want you to succeed and in
order to do that you have to fail you
have to fail forward and it's okay we
accept mistakes we're a fast-moving
organization and it's unrealistic to say
that you won't make a mistake but it's
always always always okay to ask
questions the reason why you should want
to come work for filtrus is if you're
anything like me you've you've worked
for really bad employers you've probably
worked for maybe even some corporate you
know
large companies that like i talked about
earlier have that insane structure and
just the corporate bs and that's really
what we lack here in such a great way i
was tired of trying to
stand toe-to-toe with different ceos
across different organizations and
convince them that people mattered and
that everybody should be treated equally
and the reason why diversity equity
inclusion for instance mattered was
because it equated to x amount of
dollars on their bottom line
and instead it's the it should be so
simple as do the right thing because
your people matter because it's the
right thing to do
to be human one of the ways to create a
fun environment is
you know it already exists here i think
is is what's interesting about that
there's not necessarily anything that i
have to create
for instance last night you know we went
to an escape room we played mario party
beforehand how many of you have done
that in a prior job i i know i can't say
that i have that's what makes
the relationships that work even better
that's what makes you happy to come into
work and walk through the door i live in
tampa right now and i can't wait for the
next time that i get to come back to san
diego and continue to
be with this amazing group of people
[Music]
you